depuis plusieurs mois on parle beaucoup
de s'envoyer des nude pendant longtemps
les médias un peu coincé et mais nous
faire croire qu envoyer des photos de
soie nude est un truc de jeunes un clin
d'oeil génération elle en avait plus
rien à faire de son intimité et qu'elle
était prête à tout pour buzz et pour
avoir du succès faux
[Musique]
les photos érotiques les news les poses
sexy ça touche tout le monde et parfois
même sa touche pas assez en forme ça
touche tout le monde et ça toujours
touché tout le monde en fait et dès le
17ème siècle mon pote et ouais on
pouvait se faire livrer des tableaux
représentant sa bien aimée nu par
exemple la maia de goya à la demande de
manuel godeuil goya a peint deux
tableaux d'une même personne
sa supposée maîtresse epita tudeau c'est
la même pose même décor mais pas la même
tenue en fait elle était habillée sur
une version est nu sur l'autre et la
version d'éluder était caché sous la
première et c'est grâce à un habile
mécanisme qu'on pouvait découvrir le
tableau nu balèze on pourrait aussi
parler d'elizabeth taylor dont on a
retrouvé des photos nues après sa mort
fait par son amant à son amant de
l'époque michael todd
c'est cette même idée de laisser des
photos nues de soi à l'être aimé et on
n'a pas attendu d'avoir le téléphone
pour faire ce genre de choses et pour
s'échanger du nude et honnêtement c'est
pas étonnant quand on connaît le nombre
de raisons qui nous poussent à le faire
et ces raisons on va les voir tout de
suite on les connaît grâce à de nombreux
témoignages
mais avant de vous parler des points qui
ressortent le plus dans ces témoignages
je vous parlais de choses déjà le genou
c'est quoi exactement c'est une photo de
soi nue et dans le langage contemporain
c'est généralement une photo prise par
soi même et c'est souvent des photos de
femmes mais ça peut être aussi des
photos d'hommes
même si les hommes généralement ils sont
plutôt chaud pour une autre tendance
quand on parlera tout à l'heure la
deuxième chose c'est un petit 10 km
heure attention envoyer des photos nues
à quelqu'un de consentants c'est à dire
qui peut potentiellement s'y attendre
bascoul au kef à tous les genres mais
que votre mug voilà mais envoyer des
photos nues à quelqu'un qui ne s'y
attend pas du tout ça peut être une
forme d'agression voilà donc ce soit et
c'est bien à qui vous les envoyer
maintenant que c'est dit voici trois
raison d'envoyer des nude selon celles
qui en envoie d'abord la confiance la
confiance en soi envoyé un lieu de
concevoir un garçon ou une fille c'est
une démarche très difficile il faut
accepter son corps le prendre en photo
se confronter à l image qu il renvoie
l'envoyer à quelqu'un et surtout
attendre sa réponse ou réussir à passer
ce cap nous permet du good engrangé pas
mal de confiance et surtout si la
réponse d'ailleurs de l'intéressé et que
la thèse du goût petite note à ceux qui
ne répondent jamais un texto et c est
quand même de répondre à un nude
rapportant ensuite c'est le fait
d'élever son corps et d'en être fier
bonjour juste content d'être non
sanguins dans notre corps sont bien dans
notre tête et c'est cool et du coup
c'est tout à fait normal de vouloir le
partager à son crash roi et c'est un
plaisir égoïste qui fera certainement un
heureux ou une oreille
donc pourquoi s'en priver enfin
alimenter le jeu de la séduction c'est
pas toujours évident quand on a
quelqu'un depuis très longtemps de
maintenir la flamme et bien les nude
peuvent être un excellent combustible
pour la garder voilà où il crée la
surprise
ils permettent de faire monter le désir
est d'ailleurs au delà du désir pas ça
fait toujours plaisir
en fait si vous savez que votre copain
votre copine pas si mauvaise journée
marché pas lui envoyer une petite photo
sexy c'est le fera sûrement sourire
attention c'est pas mais obtenue en moi
encore une fois c'est des témoignages
etc les points qui revient le plus
souvent
donc voilà pour les raisons principales
et les nude on va pas se mentir c'est
relativement bien reçu les digues pics
en revanche c'est une toute autre
histoire
1 beaucoup plus controversée par des
laquais semaine des pics basse et une
photo de beats souvent prises par son
propriétaire lui-même et c'est un
phénomène
énorme selon une étude menée sur 5500
célibataires aux états unis en 2016 à 49
% des femmes interrogées qui déclarent
avoir déjà reçu au moins une victime non
désirées et 47 % des sommes qu'ils
admettent avoir déjà envoyé sans
préciser s'il s'agissait de photos
sollicités ou c'est d'ailleurs assez
drôle de se dire qu'en fait il ya plus
de meuf qui reçoivent beaucoup de mecs
qui en envoie en rouille et des mecs qui
en envoie beaucoup de filles en même
temps il ya un paquet de raisons qui les
poussent à en envoyer
et en voici trois d'abord envoyer des
piques c'est une déclaration
extrêmement maladroite on va pas se
mentir mais c'est une manière pour
certains de dire à une fille qui sont
intéressés par l mais c'est aussi une
façon d'attirer l'attention que ce soit
qu'elles soient bonnes ou mauvaises qui
en fait est une théorie derrière ça
c'est celle de l'erreur management en
gros si vous pensez que n'importe qui
qui vous regardent veut de vous eh bien
vous aurez plus de chance de vous
reproduire parce que vous aurez moins de
chances de rater des opportunités alors
ça prend avec des pincettes parce que je
sais pas ce que ça vaut et faudrait
l'étudier ça beaucoup plus en détail
voilà mais ça rappelle en tout cas une
citation du grand hockeyeur wayne
gretzky tu rates tous les tirs que tu ne
tente pas ensuite certains hommes
pensent qu envoyer leur sexe en photo
c'est excitant ceci parce que ça les
excite d'en recevoir
du coup ils pensent que la réciproque
est vraie il y en a même qui pensent
qu'il faut faire l'amour comme sur
youporn vous jure et d'où ils pensent
qu'une digue pic c'est le meilleur moyen
de démarrer un jeu de séduction ou ans
comme ça directement dans le vif du
sujet et on annonce la couleur
du coup ils cherchent pas à interpeller
ou à choquer non là le mec est persuadé
que papa de la photo va plaire et ce
qu'il attend avant tout bas c'est de
recevoir un nude en retour on sait
jamais sur un malentendu ça peut marcher
et enfin comme pour les nude envoyé une
digue pic bas ça c'est un lego délivre
une partie de soi dont on est plutôt
fier et si en plus la réponse que l'on
reçoit est positive ben on a une plus
grande confiance en soi et on a un bon
ego boost à une fois encore toutes les
techniques ne sont pas envoyées avec
bienveillance
dans certains cas les hommes qui les
envoie il souhaite juste choqué ou
asseoir une domination illusoire et
comme pour un nude une dictée qui n'ont
attendu basse a peut être vécu comme une
forme de harcèlement
donc voilà il faut penser au
consentement du ou de la destinataire
d'ailleurs certains fans ont eu
tellement ras-le-bol de recevoir des
photos d'eux ils ont trouvé des moyens
assez cool et créatif pour le faire
savoir
madeleine golden a imaginé le tumblr
critiques ma technique dans lequel elle
partage des photos qu'elle reçoit avec
une petite analyse 1
du genre c'est une digue picasso simple
juste au dessus de la moyenne
même si on peut noter des efforts de
mise en scène et son blog est devenu un
véritable phénomène puisqu'elle reçoit
des centaines de photos qui ne demande
qu'à être analysés et notés
alors je me rends compte que ma
casquette en train de vivre sa vie
depuis tout à l'heure n'hésitez pas à
prévenir les drames le dire quand wise à
ce que je me suis rendu compte un petit
peu tard on peut également parler de
whitney belle elle en a lui aussi
totalement ras la casquette de recevoir
des clichés de kate et du coup elle a
décidé de faire un projet artistique
mettant en scène les clichés et les
résultats sont plutôt cool je trouve ou
qu'il fasse rire éxito agace les news et
vidic pic se sont démocratisés et sont
devenus des références universelles de
notre génération
ils existent et ils sont présents en
masse par exemple l'un des plus gros
topic de reddit s'appelle lady bonheur
gone wild et il est destiné à la
publication de photos nues d'hommes il
ya 100 clichés qui sont postés par jour
et 80000 qui sont abonnés ça souffle en
tous les cas faites vous plaisir mais
toujours en respect de l'autre envoyer
des photos de soi ça peut faire du bien
à soi même mais aussi à l'autre tant que
tout ça est fait dans le consentement
mutuel
j'espère que ça attiser votre curiosité
sur cette pratique et son historique
merci à ceux qui ont participé à mon
sondage sur snapped at il d'ailleurs mon
snaps et cirrus north tout attaché voilà
donc n'hésitez pas à m'ajouter pour
n'importe quelle raison
love peace ciao si ce n'est pas déjà
fait n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour
ne pas rater les prochaines vidéos
il n'hésitait pas à mettre un pouce pour
le référencement de la vidéo c'est
toujours cool
voilà ça fait plaisir bison
[Musique]